hi there steve here continuing my 90-day
korean challenge it's election day in
the united states i'm not going to get
on to
politics i'm going to talk again about
how excited i am about my korean
in the context of fluency
uh for a couple of reasons first of all
i appreciate everybody's comments here i
don't expect people to agree with me
and if you comment here please don't
expect me to agree with you
someone here made the comment i'm going
by memory but he said you know fluency
just means flowing flowing like a river
as long as it's flowing then you're
fluent it doesn't matter how many words
you know
so
uh of course i happen to believe that
you in order to be fluent you know
flowing like a river i mean you can have
a little trickling
stream that's flowing
very limited amount of water or you can
have you know the mississippi the nile
the volga you know massive flows
and i think that um
you know when we're when we're fluent in
a language we want to be able to
massively communicate understand
explain our thoughts
even the definition of fluency talks
about being articulate it's very hard to
be articulate if you don't have a lot of
words
and today i was thinking of this as uh
you know i was reading doing my link
here i don't know if this comes out at
all visible but
uh you know reading now some text that
i've gone through the number of yellow
words that's words that i have actually
looked up
is there's fewer and fewer of them and
there's fewer and fewer blue words and
others unknown words and so as i'm
reading these texts and rereading them
i have this sense of increasing fluency
i can read faster i understand
much better what i'm reading i get this
momentum
now i still have trouble understanding
but i'm understanding a little bit
better when i listen all right but so my
fluency in terms of my reading fluency
is i'm conscious of it uh you know
improving increasing and and it speaks
simply because i know more and more
words the more words i know the more
fluently i can read through this stuff
and eventually i'll be able to speak and
and you know just thinking about this
the sort of metaphor if you want of of
fluency being like a river
you know there's a famous greek and i
should have looked it up is it no i
can't remember who it says was um i
can't remember
greek philosopher said you never step in
the same river twice
and to me this implies that you know
time is constantly flowing
and so we never are in the same
situation again i i suppose i i suppose
that's what he meant i should have
googled it and got some learned thoughts
on this idea that you never step in the
same river twice it's constantly flowing
by you but language learning is not like
that you're constantly i'm rereading
things that i read before
i'm coming across the same words and
phrases that i saved once before and i
now see them highlighted in yellow i'm
hearing some of the same words again in
the same sometimes they listen more than
once so i hear the same thing again or i
hear the same words and phrases in
different contexts so in fact we do come
across the same
elements of what we're listening to and
sometimes we re-read and re-listen so
we do step in the same river twice so
just to deal with again this idea of
fluency and how it uh you know compares
to this idea of flowing in a river and i
want my language not to be a little
trickle of water flowing i wanted to be
a significant mass of words and
comprehension and ability to communicate
articulately and so forth and so on so
there you have it and i'm moving on with
my korean
thanks for listening and if you enjoy
these broadcasts or these excuse me
these videos please subscribe bye for
now